Wayne it is so good to see you so first
off thank you for having
me me in a very lovely Studio I feel
like I'm I'm here this is where it all
happens this is yeah it's just just the
basement yeah absolutely well you know
the when I met you it was at a Packers
game so I have to start with are you all
in on Jordan love because I was giving
you a hard time at that
game I'm all in on Jordan love because
for my personal reasons and also um for
one of them main reasons is because the
team I mean the coach the coach is all
in this you know Wisconsin Green Bay
they they all in and it's you know we I
say we I do act like I live there so
you'll hear that if we ask me any other
kind of questions in there comes out
that way so we we we have patience yeah
yeah you we we we show we show that we
have patience and also we whatever it is
about us we you know I I swear I hate
using this word but if it's the culture
oh the old culture word yeah if it's the
culture it it works because the players
end up having and I ain't talking about
Jordan love the players end up having
patience as well Aaron set before he
before we knew how amazing he was going
to be you know I mean unless you watched
him in school and that c you knew he was
going to be a dog but other than that he
set and if you watch the draft Aaron's
draft Aaron had a problem with being
drafted that late so you as a fan of
football you kind of like you wanted to
see what he was going to do the when he
get in the NFL and it took like 3 years
yeah for you to wait to see what he
going to do so we have patience and you
know so and you didn't hear anything
about the him and you know back and
forth bread stories and all you didn't
hear that nothing about that
till pretty much way later yeah yeah I
mean to your point Packers fans do a
really good job of rallying around their
guy like it means so much to them and
it's really fun going to Lambo and
seeing the houses that are just
dedicated to Packers football like it's
genuinely a lifestyle there but as you
mentioned patience I was actually
thinking about how much time and
patience that we give young quarterbacks
and wondered if it is similar to the
time and patience that you give to
develop Young Artists how much space do
you get people to grow into themselves I
Do Me Myself And um what I the way I run
mine and the way I do it my business and
my label and the way I
uh I guess
uh I I don't want to say teach or
whatever but the way I sculpt an artist
and um patience is you need patience
and art is Art is you know I mean art is
to the to the individual liking you know
there's music that I've never heard that
is number one in the country you know
what I mean so artist to your liking so
I try to make sure that the artist is is
fully belie I mean fully believable in
themselves and their art yeah and so
therefore you're able to handle not
rejection but even handle
unacceptability you know I mean you're
able to handle that because I accept my
art regardless and I'm that confident in
what I do that I already understand that
everyone isn't going to even want to
hear it or like it or view it or
whatever
so once you have that type of confidence
in what you're doing you're going to
approach what you're doing different
you're going to approach the art
different and then what your producers
should be you know and also it also has
to pass by my ears so yeah and you know
and that that's a really good point
because it's it's about being okay with
what you created even if other people
aren't yeah because then it's fine yeah
it's fine because you're sure about it
yeah yeah that's a really good way to
look at it and I think you know just
generally there are so many parallels
between Sport and music so I really
throughout this conversation want us to
think about the differences and
similarities between the two because you
have such a unique vantage point and you
are the greatest in your Arena so I I
really would enjoy your perspective on
that and to your point about art really
being in sort of the eye of the beholder
the thing about sports is there's a
clear winner Whoever has the most points
at the end won the game whatever team
wins the championship is the best team
yes and it's not the same in music yeah
so how do you win in
music
so I have experience thank God I've been
in this um like you know forever a
trillion years and so therefore I used
to be I was I was around when it was
competitive you know I was around when
there was a certain such thing called
battle rap you know and that was a form
our form of of rap where I can literally
it was almost
it was almost comedic what I mean by
that is a comedian can you know they
roast each other yeah and you know that
means they don't mean nothing by it you
know battle rap was the same you know
you got these people they standing in a
circle and you know I mean Eminem might
te your head off about something that
you felt great about yourself in the
mirror before you got there you know you
know so and then you know and then they
come right back and and do the same so
that was a that was a art form you know
what I mean they had people that to this
day there there's battle raps that went
down that that's not they aren't filmed
they aren't recorded and they there's
Legends because of the the leg the
Legends come out of that because we
don't have that no more so so I was
around during that and then when I came
out that was kind of gone but it was
still a competition the competition yeah
the competition was everyone clicked up
so if you had a you know everyone had a
click so that let you that was right
there that was the perfect example of
competition yeah that's my team that's
my team exactly you know let's get
everybody had their change you you know
what I mean everybody we just represents
my team you know now no now you going I
need 30 chains I don't even care what it
represent I just need one that say my
name I need one that say something cool
whatever the new thing is to say I need
one to say that oh my nickname need one
to say you know also oh right oh Gucci
just put that out I need that one you
know so that's a difference a big
difference so my I remember when I was
coming out and I first came out the
competition was who's what you what you
what your numbers doing that was the
competition so I remember being young
and being in the Cash Money offices and
first thing I always ran to was and this
is this is when I was like you know
number one in the country yeah and first
thing I run to is the Billboard magazine
magazine people not cuz before you know
magazine cuz that was your proof yeah to
see where I'm at if I got a square you
know I mean by my name or if I have a
damn triangle whatever I got a circle
whatever I got by my name thank God I
got a diamond um yeah so you know like
just to see what I got by my name and
see who under my name and see who over
my name you know and so that was a thing
you know like that was a and even cash
when we had our own our own competition
amongst numbers selling album sales
within our within the team you know like
juvenile came out like went platinum in
his first week that was the bar mhm that
was the bar okay you got to go platinum
your first week I think I came out my um
with my first solo album and I went gold
first week and you know to I was like
okay I ain't juvie so I wasn't expecting
to do what juvie do but then I went pla
like the next that whole that month yeah
and so we was I mean so we
now man you can just make a little snap
your fingers dance and that might sell
more than Lil Wayne never I mean my
whole album yeah yeah you know so it's a
I don't even know what how they compete
now I don't even know what the
competition because me I'm still running
around calling myself the best rapper
alive and living up to it y so to be the
best at something you have to have
someone that's not the best you have to
be going against something that's not
the best yeah and that's the whole game
absolutely and I mean it it sounds like
too it's like do you kind do you miss
those days of the competition um I would
say I would say no no because if I were
to miss it that mean I'm holding on to
it and I don't know how to adapt and and
I would be also I would be lying to say
if I miss it because I'm so much forward
trying to you know move I so I'm so into
moving forward and adapt I mean adapting
that I really forgot I'm until you ask I
forgot those days you asked about yeah
well then so as you think about it in
the vein of like you know rap still in
some ways feeling competitive what does
practice look like to you what is it
that you do to be better every single
day I do always I do what I do what what
an artist probably carve out a time in
their year to earn the schedule ear the
day to do I live that I don't have I
carve out a time to
do regular life that type of stuff like
breathe stuff like that you know like I
have kids at car out of time to remember
you have kids and oh what do you do with
kids you know and that type of thing
yeah for real yeah you know like that's
because I live this I live you know I I
live in here I came here and I'm late
here because I was at my house in my own
Studio working on something else and I
live this you know like in my studio is
in my guest house my house is 45 times
bigger than my guest house every time
somebody come over there they like
that's your house like yeah they like
why we ain't in there like we here and
they could look around and just see by
all the stuff that's in there just the
stuff that everyday life stuff that you
living in here and if I take them
upstairs they can see how clean upstairs
look like I'm look like I'm trying to
sell the house yeah you know what I mean
so and they can see that like you don't
live in here you know and so that's what
I guess practice is to me that's just
doing it I do it every day yeah I need a
reason not to do it a reason to do you
know as I've watched a lot of your
interviews and was reading a lot of your
articles you talk a lot about you know
this Obsession that you have with this
and that shows in what you put out that
it is something that means something to
you that it is a lifestyle but what
separates people that are obsessed with
this and the people that love it because
those aren't the same thing so I still
believe that the people that love it
they they they're human and so they know
how to carve out time for the things
that's actually important to
them you know what I mean and so they CU
you can love a billion things you know
so they just like you said they can love
this but they may also love their kids
and they may also love the car they may
also love the look so you may love what
you just did the song the album and then
you may love the attention you got from
it and forget how to do another album me
I'm obsessed with this so I actually
don't even know about the attention you
know I got to be reminded I gotta even
be told you know and that's why I think
people see the the organic response or
the like you know he really he really
loves us you know he really respects the
anyone that respects him and respects
what he does because he love what he
does so damn much he's obsessed with it
that if you have any inklet of a respect
for it or like for it or don't tell me
you love it then I can't do no he he is
in me I honor you yeah this is what I do
it for you are what I do it for I don't
do it for myself if I done it for myself
then I'd have been stopped yeah yeah cuz
I got enough I just told you how big the
house is so you're like I'm myself yeah
yeah you know so I was um I was talking
to Kevin Durant about how I was doing
this interview and he said that he had a
question okay and the question that he
wants me to ask you is are you going to
drop a snippet of you all song on the
radio
[Laughter]
show see I see why would K do that
because see I'm you know I'm a true you
already know you know I'm a true that
was that was on the rap that was on the
low I was not you see KD you messed up
now now that you done that I just want
you to know you messed up the out that
song was being considered to be on
carter6 and I said you said something
it's not
going now you ruined it no uh no I'm not
playing to sniff it cuz I just told the
people how important the song get the
verse is it actually was supposed to go
on uh the KY Grove welcome to KY Gro
album with me in two chains that just
came out
but I I I I you know I saved it I want
for something else yeah he kind of go
crazy on there so yeah well when I asked
about it him about it he said to ask you
so give me tell me about it what is he
like as as an artist in the studio I
wasn't in the studio with him he sent it
that's another thing these days totally
different yeah you know back then you
had to actually meet up with the person
you know go to Studio deal with their
Entourage and your entourage too you
know all that all that had to go and so
but now you know there a text yeah you
text the song I text it back to you when
I finish you know literally and he did
and um as far as his style to me KD's a
a you know he's um he's a what you call
it he's a
a jewel you know like something of of
the past because he's a backpack rapper
I can imagine KD probably could rap
right you know I can imagine you
probably could call a timeout in the
game and probably ask him to rap and he
probably got he got a verse for you fire
yeah you know me I you know I'm so
perfectionist I need hold on hold on
hold on hold on you know you know I need
hold on I might Tred to say something
about what what's going on and all that
you know KD probably just got bars yeah
and it sounds like it I love that you
know I would say to him like you know as
he's been getting some into being an anr
some producing obviously some actually
using his voice I was saying to him like
you know Shaq's second phase of his
career was TV sha that we see but we
know him as that I think it'd be really
cool that whenever KD is no longer in
the basketball court if his second phase
of his career is music and we know him
for that I think would be really fire
for him because he does love it to your
point n you to to rap the way he does
you you have to put time in it that way
and also you could you could hear a you
can hear a kind of a innate you can kind
of hear a it's just a him it's just him
in it you know what I mean something
like you know almost the way he plays
yeah you know that just almost like it's
I don't want to use the word like a
desal but almost like it's just too easy
smooth yeah you can hear that in a you
you can hear that I didn't I didn't have
to do too much thinking for him how good
that bar was yeah you know about that
what they say about KD easy easy money
easy money yeah definitely yeah
absolutely so for you would you say that
rapping is more of like a football
mindset or a basketball mindset me I
would say the way I approach it I would
say is definitely the quarterback
mindset I got to know whatever I got to
know this that that that that that that
I might switch up might call it audible
also I need to play well on the road
meaning features yeah and you do
that yeah I love that okay so if you
think about the sports landscape what
right I'll think about the NBA you have
Steph who's a shooter Giannis is
dominant Katie is an unguardable
scorer what are you in the rap game what
do you do the best me I do me the best
um I would
say I would say that I'm
uh like a
LeBron know the F I'm I started I
dropped my first solo album when I was
14 and that's the Same album I'm talking
about that went in Platinum so the fom
that came out and I stuck some that came
out and I've been doing this at this
pace of higher ever since just like him
and you're kind of still right now today
is kind of
like it's so crazy that you remember Tom
Brady was remember every year was still
even though he was winning the Super
Bowl and all it still was is this a year
he going to retire is this the year he
going we don't even say that about we
don't want you to retire yeah we want
you to stay forever that's what I'm
saying so I kind of look at that as when
people ask me like when the Carter Six
coming out I like God damn it that's six
of them and they still want it and
that's how I look at that you know so I
am so happy that you explained it in
that way because I had this thought
today that I I feel like people don't
realize that you were one of the first
like young stars that actually became a
superstar that you have done this your
whole life and I think about LeBron I
think about
Serena and the ways that you all met the
expectation but then exceeded the
expectation and it is very rare to
become the person that you're supposed
to become do you ever sit and think
about that definitely because being that
person you was talking about you that
you in your head you can only imagine
what the what the person you set to be I
don't think we ever you know even if we
do get to that person we automatically
set another person you know what I'm
saying so I think that's and that's the
reason why I still work the way I work
every day yeah and also from coming from
so young back then I think the longevity
thing was the approach you know cuz we
knew not to approach it that way you
know cuz I was literally the same age
and stuff as Lil Bow and Lil Romeo and
stuff you know like I had shows and we
would have I but I'm not about to get on
here and talk about what they talk about
I'm going to talk about what's real to
me and that's it was already a doubt
conversation yeah you know and so it
already made me that's my long meaning
so therefore if I'm starting off here
and I'm only 14 I can I got time to make
it to an adult actually 100% start
meaning what I say yeah sure like time
to get there yeah so going off of that
how did expectations help you and how
did expectations hurt you
um obviously helped me it by just doing
what you said earlier by exceeding them
yeah by knowing and by knowing that I
can you know so I thank you I think you
would get that but that just that's just
by confirmation of of anybody by just a
crowd a crowd of two people or whatever
ever so I got that confirmation already
from my grandmother when I was five 6
years old being woken up at 10 10 p.m.
to come through the Michael Jackson you
know things like that you know sing this
song sing that song and they and and
seeing the the satisfaction of older
this is my grandmother this ain't no my
mom this is my grandmother so they got
older people so seeing the satisfaction
of them and being able to go back to
sleep with a smile on or being a to get
a treat or what a get a something out
the fridge that you know so things like
that that's my confirmation that okay
I'm you know what I mean I'm all right
so that I think that right there was all
the person like that person that I would
I mean all that I need so it really
wasn't nothing else other than you know
I mean I I'm able to channel back to
that anytime for sure yeah so with you
know this being so much of your life and
it's what you're used to one thing I was
going to ask you was you know how much
of your identity is tied to you as an
artist but I feel like at least from
what you've said so far it's like that
is your identity oh no that is who I
yeah that's that's exactly who I am I
don't again I think that's the person
that loves it that knows how to be
someone else or be themselves you know
and turn it I always say I always say
um I was like I was when I was younger
and um baby baby my my Pop's better man
he would be around so many damn artists
so I remember when he would be around
you know artists that I was seeing on TV
here already and I would notice that
when they go record when it's time for
them to record I would notice that all
you know we talking the whole time they
in there talking and when they record
all of a sudden a new voice you know
they got to get ready to and I was like
wow like it would seemed cool I like I'm
still a kid and to me you you being a
superhero you turn into who you about to
be you know you about to be this
character yeah you know so it was still
kind of cool to me but at the end of the
day I knew that I couldn't be some
character I was too young
if if I wanted to be the character at
that age then the character was the
little guy the little I couldn't be that
around these guys no they not talking
about that and they not living that and
so I couldn't there was no character to
be I was just the the little kid that's
cool enough to be around these guys and
so that's what I made myself and that's
what I made the most of yeah yeah like
the the youth or the not having these
certain experiences yet actually helped
you find what made you you which is like
a really beautiful way to think about it
and so like you said this is me yeah for
sure so I also think you know I saw I
saw the clip where you discussed the
ways that your life has expanded as you
got older that as you got older there
was just everything to wrap about how
has experience made you a better artist
and why was it depressing to hear
otherwise
well I mean just technically experience
made me a better better artist by just
being able to just the experience alone
just the longevity alone being able to
hear yourself you know being able to
hear yourself and seeing reactions and
seeing reactions to this and being able
to thank God have the time I'm able to
the time I was able I'm able to have to
be able to do different types of music
and see the reaction to the different
types of music and people be able to
come up to you and tell you what the the
the type they like the most from you you
know what I mean so just things like
that that's where the that's where the
experience come in and I'm still trying
to I mean I guess the the I guess the
disappointment to that would be also you
it's impossible for you not to judge
yourself you know and so it's it's
impossible for for you not to
say when you see some when you see what
they like you wish they loved and you
see the stuff that they loved you it's
not that you wish they didn't love it
you just man I wish that attention was
paid to this and then so you try to
figure out a way to get it and all that
typee of stuff so I don't want to say
disappointment I guess the
disappointment would be just you I guess
not meeting your own your own whatever
expectations you set yeah yeah okay so
that that's super interesting what you
just said I've never heard anybody frame
it that way can you expand on what you
mean by it it makes it hard not to judge
yourself yeah I
mean
so just for the simple you know for
something like you can get you can get
you can get a you can
have an you can have an album I mean you
can have a wave going you know already
to and you're this person and you're
that and they know they know you for
this or they know you for that or
whatever and then all of a sudden you
can be you know there's a lot of artists
that use that use that platform and say
now it's time for me to show them who I
am and so therefore you didn't start off
with who you were so but it's okay cuz
you whatever character you did it worked
yeah you know it's okay and I mean this
is this is America it's okay you f it
you f it till you make it you know what
I mean so it's okay but then there's
people that's you know that through this
thing we do music yeah I want to now I
want to show you what I can who I am and
what and you then then you put something
out and they don't even like it they
don't even listen to it and that can and
so that make you that can make you judge
yourself and that can make you feel like
wait I'm not this person I'm not this
this other character whatever so I got
to be that for y'all to like me I got to
put on the the hat and the the you know
I mean this the umbrella and all that
for you to like man I really wish you
wanted me to be so that that goes back
to that question you asked me about you
know like even a question of love and
Obsession and when you ask me the
question about that you it seems like I
live it so what I mean by that
is I am
this you're like I am this you know like
and you see a bunch of them now are you
like I am this you know so I don't what
I mean by that is I'm
I still get fussed at by my mom you know
like please stop messing up your face
you know like I'm quite sure they
probably don't it's probably now that's
just a thing now you know like I am like
this stuff means stuff and I'm from the
era where when you put it on your face
it better mean
something and so there's the it's huge
difference you know so that I I live it
and
so I guess and I guess that I guess yes
to answer that that's is everything else
then it' be impossible for you not to
you know I mean for you not to at least
get disappointed at some at some point
if they don't accept who you actually
are when this is who I am and I'm thank
God gratefully accept so much accepted
that you look just like me yeah yeah
you're like for for you maybe this is a
character but for me yeah it's me yeah
so I'm not putting this on or taking it
off oh you trust me when I get them when
I when I'm with when I'm with a lot of
artists and they still around me like
you know like like d you do it like like
d you do that like and I'm looking at
them like you
don't you like you don't yeah I thought
you I'm look I was trying to find figure
out find some new stuff from you you
know and you come around me a but thank
God because it's how hard I work and I
appreciate the love yeah absolutely you
know as you're talking about this I
think about so about every season I talk
to Dear de R roen about the mid-range
that's something that we always discuss
and he always tells me that he thinks
about what Kobe said to him which is
that you have to stay true to yourself
he says he that plays in his mind over
and over and he says everyone around me
is shooting threes why would I feel like
I had to shoot threes if I know I can
get to one spot that is unguardable and
Unstoppable and he does it yes he's like
why would I feel like I have to change
because everybody else has how have you
like resisted that sort of
change easy being obsessed with what I
do and myself and my craft so much to
where you know I always go to this one
example so much to where you do an
interview and they ask you hey so what
do you think about 21 Savage and your
honest answer to that is wow there's a
new rap group with 21 artists
that must be like the new wuang and have
21 pissed off at you cuz he thinking you
did that on
perpose he was like you know what I went
back and saw that he like man he was
serious he like I found out more about
him so that's how you know like
literally being caught up into what I do
to I'm never finished so I have no time
to know and then you know the only way I
really do know what's going on I got
kids yeah you know I got kids and you
know when they come inside and you're
like what the hell is that and you're
like why would you want to do that and
then you look on TV you see the number
one football player the number one
college number one artist doing it like
oh okay it's a wave yeah it's the thing
it's a wave it's a thing to do so it's
really just like having tunnel vision
and saying like all I can focus on is
what I'm doing because that's the thing
that matters to me yeah yeah that's all
I mean this is what we if you do it this
what we do
that's why I try to tell like stop being
so amazed that I don't do anything
else like you don't do you care about
what these people listen to when that
comes from you cuz if you care then I
don't think you have time for nothing
else yeah just like we talk about these
athletes like we talk about LeBron that
you hear about what he do in the off
seon for his body and he
cares you know like that's why you know
and it's this thousand year you don't
have to do that you should already the
machine that's named after him for
whatever he does you know what I mean
and no if it is named after him he's
still doing it totally you know so
that's what I mean by that you know you
don't you know I mean so you you either
I don't have time to I'm working on my
jumper you know like I'm working I'm
still working on mine I'm still judging
myself when I make a thousand and should
have made a
th1 you know and so and until I'm
stopped until that's not me until so I I
don't have that no more then beware yeah
beware mhm you said before that true
artists and Pioneers never retire and
that made me think about LeBron because
as someone who has achieved
greatness what do you think the term
retirement signifies to
LeBron what I think what I think um what
Brian is going to you get to a point
obviously with experience and thank god
with success and failure you get to a
point where you understand that okay
retirement means something different I
don't care what it mean to whoever
saying it means something different to
me you know and so with that mean I
think LeBron is going to understand that
obviously he plays a sport you can't do
that forever but then that's his
son and his other son his a daughter
then there's also just his his agency
then there also the opportunity to you
got you got you got the commissioner or
whatever they're already making jokes
I'm sorry couldn't give him a franchise
that mean he's going to have a
franchise you know so like so what I
mean by that is and that's going to take
on something totally that's going to
require more of him and if he's going to
he's going to not if he's going to
approach it the way you approach
everything and there it is he's not
retired yeah and he's still doing what
and obviously I did the same you know I
remember I couldn't I remember I never
even saw myself even having a label and
no such thing as artist with me I looked
at it like no whoever the label is
whoever the artist is I'm going bite
your head I'm the best all of a sudden
Young Money and all of a sudden there's
a Drake and there's a Nikki and there's
tigers and you know what I mean so and I
never never but it's because I
approached it that way the reason why
Young Money became what it was know I
mean because I can honestly tell you I
was just ready to eat your Young Money
up yep
until times change yeah things
change there are truly so many parallels
it seems like between you and LeBron
have you ever been able to like like
have a conversation with him about this
no I haven't um actually the funniest
thing is when I was younger I had a show
in like Ohio somewhere and it was me and
I want to say J
Ru me and J we did a bunch of shows
together um back then and I remember um
slim slim that's his that's birman's
older brother he asked me he's been into
he's very deep into sports so he's like
one of them people that like know
somebody that's like coming from high
school like way from Tim Buck to
what he got the he know the stats and
like so because we know him for that he
was like you know Wayne you got a show
in Ohio I got I got a little basketball
player through he like the best bro he
GNA be number one he won't come to your
show you know we know you for this Slim
So Okay cool whatever so we get toio you
know I get told remember the dude slim
told you about he downstairs he cool he
could tell him follow us I remember you
know um I think Joelle Santan whatever
came to my room so I we talking and we
and chilled up in the room for like 2
and 1 half hours and I remember being
reminded as I walking to my bus you know
now as I'm going that's the little dude
in the truck right there like you
talking about the dude you told me that
that slim like he's still down here like
yeah that's him right I said go so when
I met him and stuff he had a broken he
had armor casts and stuff I remember
they didn't want nobody to see that like
that's that's I remember that was
something I peeed cuz I a know nothing
about that M I was like I want nobody no
they was like he that bad he that cold
they want like I never heard nothing
like he cold and I never even know you
can't show that you hurt
yeah no one can know like I don't even
know who he is I remember all his whole
little crew and I'm quite sure the crew
was probably rich rich and all just
little boys then yeah all had on little
long white t-shirts and jeans like I did
and so I remember that remember that
yesterday yeah and I remember and I just
remember to myself he must be a real
must have been a real fan yeah been a
real fan I just felt like I'm not
missing this moment or something but we
all had a great time I love that story
and there's something that's like a
little kissm about that like that
serendipitous like that you guys had
this moment before he became before I
became yes I that's like genuinely one
of my favorite stories like when baby
and first thought you know he was I'm I
am you know baby considered me a son so
when he first allowed me to start going
on the road by myself so that's why slim
with like you know you got a show in C
Ohio right yeah they got this little
basketball player he he want to come to
your show come hook that up like
whatever yeah cool yeah do it okay there
are some things that are meant to be
yeah then I remember saying like wow
like he became you know like cuz you
know how you just you just is isn't you
just automatically keep up with that
person you just you know I mean you
start I started seeing them in the you
know in the J the um the school the
green jerse the gold like
that's
slime I'm like where from I'm like
that's him with the little head like
yeah that's him like they talking about
he going to go number one out of high
school like nah like talking about the
chosen one another what sports illust
what I'm talking about when I saw that
I'm like this slime from the show yeah
like y'all don't you know the homies
don't remember right they don't remember
anything so you got to call Slim slim it
was LeBron James that like yeah I'm like
fire yeah I'm like bro I remember that
like I'm like you like remember alone
they said
downstair yeah to see you that is like
that's a great story I love that so much
and then of course now he is King James
that's 24 hours to meet him yeah now
good luck and I wait for them I was just
to go to the games trust me for sure you
know there's obviously always so much
talk around the NBA right now of okay
what are we going to do after after
LeBron retires who do you feel like
should be face of the NBA who has it
all I mean obviously when I say
Obviously and to me I think the obvious
answer is
J because the NBA is entertaining it's
always happen what I mean by that is
that was always a Michael Jordan and
that was just like you know like God and
then you know but that was also you
going to watch these Atlanta hwk games
just to see what um Dominique just to
see if he going to get him one off I'm
going to watch these Poland games to see
if Clyde going get him one I'm going to
even watch these boring ass Jazz games
to see what the see what the mail man
the John GNA do and man I'm about to
watch these Phoenix games to see about
Steve and and they ain't none of them
probably going to make to the playoffs
you know but it was fun it was fun so I
think that's that and also ja ja's teams
are are actually competitive when he's
there and when he's doing his thing
so I think ja but you know after that
you got Zion and of course I think it'd
be Blasphemous for me not to say wmy
yeah yeah and he he looked so good in
the beginning obviously the Spurs are
losing but it was so clear the minute he
slept on the court you said yeah this is
different the the rumors are GL I'm glad
he saw that I'm glad he saw that I'm
glad he he start noticing that hold on
yeah a hand on my back is the defensive
stop for me like hold I got to get now
hold on like that was the defense yeah
yo hand on his back what I got to get
right emo Cheerios or something weedies
all the stuff you got to do something do
you remember the first game that you sat
courtside at yeah I think it was a
probably it was probably a New Orleans
Hornets game okay yeah because you know
that was that was the new thing in town
and you know and you think you're
somebody so you feeling like I got to be
there you know and I got to be cide so
then I got season tickets and they of
course had season tickets so it
definitely was the harness and it's it's
so hard to go back once you sit there
one time you know it's like well I tried
to sweep before it was like oh no this
ain't it not the same thing I want to be
able to hear everything I you know they
come H at you I'm I'm usually with my
sons that's cool as hell in my kid for
sure I love that know you knew him yeah
you know him I didn't know I know him NE
but he know
me I love that I love that yeah I know
like Bach report had you on the
Courtside Cam and you all had some
really nice moments doing that um okay
so my son also plays for the Lakers too
yeah he looks just like Max chrisy what
what we'll do it side by side nah you
got no serious man I've I've told him
that I told so you know when you tell
his mom that right she didn't hit me
with like at least three different NBA
players they call me like yo you saw
this dude your son next and Brian being
in one of them LeBron yes LeBron told
her like yo you never some Max
Christie CP being onep and I'm like
yo cam like next to like Max
Christie okay that is funny I love he
look just like and even TNS and and now
you know when you admit it you know you
you know cuz somebody could tell you you
look like somebody all day You' be like
I don't see myself but he's like he had
no choice but to say okay he was like he
does kind of look like me I like no you
look like him cam I like no you know
what y'all probably are the same age
yeah
yeah okay so let's think about this for
a second Lil Wayne headline Super Bowl
in New Orleans how badly do you want to
hear those
words just as bad as I want want to see
my name at the top of that list when I
was that whatever age it was and I would
bust into the office and get that
billboard magazine
M yeah bad yeah why what does it signify
to you what does it mean to do that uh
think it you know just as an artist you
know because this has nothing to do with
and that's so crazy that it has nothing
to do with the sport as an artist yeah
as an artist this this is an
achievement as an art that has nothing
to do with the sport that's so crazy it
has I don't care what teams are playing
what city is in that you perform for the
what yeah right excuse me you know I me
like what like oh man so that right
there is just it's an achievement it's a
you know and thank God I've been on the
Grammy stage you know and my name has
been called and I've won and nah I can
tell you that and I performed at the
grammies and that's an amazing the
reason why that's probably the next
highest feeling of but uh and I know for
a fact that when I do the Louisiana Fest
MH there that there's like a trillion
people out and and being in front of my
city and seeing that many people is
amazing so that right there is a a crazy
feeling so to know that a Super Bowl
would be what yeah what that would be
that would be a little and I by being
going to Super Bowl before and watching
the halftime show it's nothing like it
and wish it you know like when you see
the artist you like I know they could
have sung the song that I was featured
on I'm featuring on everybody song yeah
they could have me you could have
brought me out could have brought me out
so I mean you are new like what does
without you know giving anything too
crazy away you know if when this happens
cuz we manifest here what does it look
like to you like is it bringing people
out what would makes your halftime show
so special please do not where the
camera at please do not feel disrespect
that if you an artist from New Orleans
or artist tied to me in any kind of way
in the music but no that's my moment and
I earn that moment so no I'm not
bringing new one I'm I'm I'm singing all
the h that you made you wrote I'm
singing them Bobby Valentino all y'all
I'm singing them I'm sorry I am so sorry
oh new what like this me I might out
like a New Orleans Jazz great or
something like that you know like
something like that you know you also
have a lot of just features like maybe
if you wanted to spinkle a little
something if I have a song with Beyonce
or something at the time please you know
Beyonce you know if I have a song with
Beyonce then of course
of course and that's just that makes no
sense not to other than that M Tay T can
make it maybe Tay take but if the Chiefs
is actually playing in it then no we're
not doing
it you said Taylor can be on my stage
rooting for the
Chiefs that is so funny I mean I I heard
you say that and I was like yes
obviously it is the obvious choice
because like why do you feel like it's
important for
the halim show to reflect the people of
the
city because you that's because there's
so many people that's not from the city
there so it's a
showcase you know and it's something
that tourists take back with them you
know and everybody not coming from a
American city people coming from out the
country they going to remember that you
know they going to remember okay I went
to New Orleans for the game I want them
to almost kind of know I mean forget to
I kind of remember the halftime I
remember the food I remember the so you
know it's a showcase and I want to I
believe that I'm I'm a part of the New
Orleans showcase yeah you absolutely are
I hope so you know one of my favorite
things about your sports fandom is that
you watch women sports and you are an
avid follower of them I saw you Tweeting
about Caitlyn Clark um obviously you are
a big fan Kaitlin CLK I mean she's so
good disrespectful it's
unreal disrespectful it's just nasty
when you watch her
just St and when you asked me about the
face I I wanted to say St I was like but
you know he up there in age yeah yeah
yeah but yeah I saw your cheat about
Caitlyn Clark um I obviously know that
you have a good relationship with Angel
Reese and LSU um and I love angel and I
wanted to talk to you a little bit yes
and Coach Moi that's my real connection
yes coach Moi we got to shout shout her
out um I wanted to talk to you a little
bit about angel Reese because you know
she has been very vocal about how she's
been dealing with some personal
struggles what advice would you have for
Angel just about the adjustment from
normal life to all eyeses on you even
when it's
hard well Angels first of all Angel is a
smart a smart young lady very smart and
so she takes time to think about the
decision she she's going to make rather
rather in your opinion they're right or
wrong she takes time to think about them
before she make come and so Angel has
also you know Angel has reached out to
me before and not even about this
situation just about advice period And
so with that said I you know at my in my
age when I was her age I wasn't reaching
out to nobody especially no one in my
position you know I was I may I may have
been observing you know what I mean and
which is also just a tells of the
difference in times yeah you know when
you could just be like you know what let
me hit
little so so with that said though she's
a she's a great human being and so I
would the advice I would give her though
about that what you asked is just
Embrace every part of it you know
Embrace every Embrace every single part
of it cuz if you do then you will know
that it will never be always amazing
yeah it will never be always good it
will probably be majority of tough not
bad but majority be tough and so you you
enjoy the good and the amazing much much
more I love that and it is true you know
when people say like great power comes
with great responsibility it's like when
you reach a certain level that is just
sort of what's a part of it yes and it
kind of becomes on you to learn how to
deal with it deal with that and even
though it's hard and that's when you
make a decision that's when you make a
decision because what they do you know
when I say they I mean athletes yeah you
know we got to hear a story about an
athlete that didn't didn't start playing
when he was that he or she was a kid you
know so with said they've been they've
been doing this from you know I mean
since forever so when they come to that
point where I got to make a decision to
either live
this it's kind of easier for them
because it is them yeah you know so
that's why you you know you but you have
to be a LeBron though to take it to
where you where you you take it to those
type of heights to where this is that's
when you make those other decisions like
and you still making that's when you're
making that same decision and it's over
it's outweighing all these when the life
brings on important important and
important important decisions to make
and that that that choice you made way
when when you was a kid and I'm just
going to still be this it's still
outweighing how how important that that
question how you've grown yeah and so
that's that's huge yeah you know cuz you
you you CH you choose yourself over a
lot of things you know and that could be
viewed from other people is different I
mean you choose yourself over with
things that's that other people value or
die for yeah you know and you choosing
your
craft there holidays you know things
like people keep asking me like so what
you what you doing for like I'm hoping I
got a show or something yeah you know
and I I heard someone as uh as some as
someone um as will buying like what you
like where you going to be like uh like
on TV entertaining the masses and I was
like that's what like y'all forgot like
that's what we that's what we are like
we don't carve out time for Christmas
that's for the artist that are
artists you know that that are whatever
the name is they that and they got a
real name after that no my name is Lil
Wayne yeah my name is Dwayne
right I'm not little such and such or
this no I'm Little Wayne we just took
the d off cuz you know my mom with me we
we was cool too cool with my dad so you
know so all this is real yeah that's
what I mean by that so you no so it's a
confirmation of What You Do by you not
by me being the way I am not knowing
what they talking about not listening to
what's going on so when I do produce
with my my product if you like it that
mean you like me cuz I can't give you
nothing that's like this like that I
like this I like that or trendy and no I
can just take my my shot is coming out
to Pure darkness and if you share light
on it then you're shedding light on it
little Wayne yeah that's all and that
that probably also feels just really
good for you personally and that's
longevity that's why I tell my artist
you know like we do when these guys do
tours book tours for me and my artists
got to come on the tour and you know
like five or four artists come for on
the first half of the tour and then the
other artist come for the second half I
like bro you see I got first Hales and
second halfes to like what's my new
album again that I just put out like we
go on stage and sing lollipop bro want
stage and sing songs that's older than
you Timeless yeah like and guess what I
sing them [__] performing like
I recorded it last night you know and so
therefore when you do it that way it's
longevity yeah you know I mean I look I
always tell them I'm like you know Vegas
coming when I'm when I'm when I'm tired
and R tired doing Vegas I'm like you got
to make sure you have music to like you
can't get in Vegas
with cuz they got another they got
another L they Ain got another how of
Love they got another little Wayne yeah
one of my favorite Clips ever and I'm
just thinking about as you're talking
about this there's this clip of Denzel
Washington on a red carpet and the the
interviewer says what are you most proud
of in your career and he says the
career like I am I'm proud of the
longevity like I'm proud that I'm still
here like talking you there's I don't
have moments because my career is so
expansive and I feel like that really is
like the goal and especially for you
it's like your career
has so many arms even as I was prepping
for this you I'm thinking
like you have Nicki Minaj and Drake in
so many ways you are responsible for
this generation of music do you think
about it that way um I I get told that a
lot you know and um and my answer to it
is always the same I always say I always
like I maybe to look like like cuz if
like y' like cuz I don't sound like that
like always sound I say the same thing
every time like like I don't sound like
the S telling me I was like what you
like maybe they look like a you maybe
they look and act and say some risque a
stuff that I would have like and they do
give me a lot of love in their music
they give me a lot of love you know and
they and when I see see any artists of
this area they they show the most utmost
respect and I see they don't even do it
show them maybe amongst Each Other M but
they it's like all that's erase and it's
we just they respect so I respect all
that but when you say resp when you say
responsible for the you know like the
maybe the look and maybe the attitude
and maybe the the again the risate and I
don't give you know like don't I don't
give her and I'm going to make sure this
works and I'm going to stand on this and
that type of thing like maybe they get
that from me other than that I think if
you
as far as the craft oh no oh no you got
to be you if the craft then we'll have a
world full of great we have we have the
music industry of a wonderful thing yeah
yeah what level of just joy and pride do
you get when you think about what Drake
has
become it's no more no less
than you know you know we know how
Sports so I was say
no more no less
than
DJ when he first got in one dude got
hurt and the the commentator scrambling
and like this is
DJ and then as he he start killing it
and now all of a sudden they got to show
a shout to his dad in the crowd and they
got to dig up his dad's history you know
his dad used to be a security for the
number one artist that Chris Browns and
Little Wayne and and when they show his
dad and the look at his dad you know me
I know big V I know his that obviously
it's my security and it's all that that
is that feeling I'm
saying here it come here it come and
then then when I say here it come is
like knowing that oh I already knew this
y'all just same feeling that Mr deito is
getting yeah the same feeling that M
that the
parties get when they when they at again
watching what he's doing the same thing
just like it's amazing but it's also in
there CU I knew what it was and I knew
what it and but to me it's more I get
more Pride I was more I get I was more
happier for what what it did for to him
how he felt about it how he feels about
it you know I mean like you know like
it's also awesome how everybody feel
about him but to see you know something
it's like you know like you a coach and
you telling them no I need you to need
you to three stop and let three three
stop drop three steps and let go the
ball I need you to make a decision and
you know that that that kid being great
already and they never made that
decision looking at you like why do I
have to start making it now and the time
you make a decision he wins a and your
it all yeah and they come run up to you
and and let you and remind you I made
that I did the three stars yeah yeah
that's the exact same fil the end yeah
it's multiplied that feeling is
Multiplied when it's
Nikki M I love that just like a a pride
and also like I knew I discovered Nikki
different yeah differently Nikki I found
Nikki Nikki was I found her yeah yeah I
love that okay a few more for you I only
have about five minutes but I was
actually telling Drake about this quote
it was when I was watching madmen and it
said even though success is a reality
its effects are temporary MH you still
get hungry even though you've eaten
MH whoever said that was not lying yeah
do you think you will ever feel
full uh no I think if I do that would be
the day I
stop yeah
so that's why when you were saying
that's why I I would I was I want to
point I mean that's why I would point
out the fact that I I use the
gramys the gr like performing at the
Grammys or winning a Grammy I use that
as the as the bar as under the bar you
know like there's some people that like
what else I got to do yeah you know like
I don't want a Grammy I've been
nominated for a gram what like I ain't
got nothing got that's some you know and
I and I respect you because that is the
Pinnacle of what of what we do but then
there your own
Pinnacle and I'm quite sure if I perform
at the Super Bowl even if I'm just
featured that that even if if I'm there
it's amazing for that night yeah it's
amazing for for that night now what's
next you know like hey Roger I heard you
taking I heard you taking this game over
International you I would love to be
thought about you know things like that
yeah when you were on the pivot you were
talking about this because you were
about to get an award and you said the
awards I get are way too late because
I've been going hard and I'm not going
to disrespect how great I am do you feel
like you have gotten all of the flowers
that you so rightfully deserve from this
industry definitely because I told you
when it's real like this and when you do
it the way I do it the just giving me
the dirt to grow flowers it's just
that's that's enough so I told you so
every every single petal matters yeah
amazing okay last one for you I want to
know your like what is your Elite
highlight film like if somebody said
this is L Wayne what song would you want
them to play oh a Milly
Millie yeah yeah that was him yeah and
only only
because Carter six ain't dropped
yet so if it was something that was
going to
be classic or whatever like that that if
I I mean that I have to answer this
question it Be A Millie It Be A Millie
but dance is always the song that I
haven't recorded yet yeah yeah so
there's always something else to chase
there's always something else to do yeah
I love that well I have to say I mean
you can ask a few people in this room
when I was at asked who I wanted to come
on my show I mean years ago I said Lil
Wayne like I we were talking about this
on the way here you were like just the
soundtrack of so much of my life and so
to be able to be here and talk to you
and just like pick your brain and see
your perspective on different things has
genuinely been a joy so I mean it from
the bottom of my heart when I say thank
you for your time and for agreeing to do
this and thank you for letting me know
that I appreciate course absolutely you
are amazing thank you
absolutely
[Music]